pour ceux qui étaient assez vieux en
1998 la crise du verglas reste
inoubliable c'est la plus grande crise
du genre de l'histoire du Canada
du 5 au 10 janvier 1998 le sud de la
province reçoit 100 mm de plus vers
glaçons 3000 km de lignes électriques ça
fait la moitié du Québec et 10% de
l'Ontario sont privés d'électricité les
Monsieur et Madame en haut à l'aide
Hydro-Québec arrêté de penser qu'on va
l'électricité dans séjour ici je le dis
et je le répète ça ressemble à la Bosnie
12000 militaires viennent en renfort
leur priorité dégager les voix au final
35 personnes perdent la vie et 600 000
sont déplacés
mais d'autres épisodes importants de
verglas ont marqué l'histoire du pays en
1984 la province de Terre-Neuve et
Labrador reçoit 25 mm de verglas en deux
jours
1000 poteaux électriques ainsi que des
dizaines de pilons sont tombés plongeant
200 000 résidents la moitié de la
province dans le noir dans certains cas
jusqu'à une semaine
en 2017 cette fois c'est au tour du
Nouveau-Brunswick d'être complètement
givré entre le 24 et le 26 janvier 50 mm
de plus vers glaçante transforme le
paysage pénurie d'essence manque de
bougies tout est paralysé c'est le Far
West dans les stations-service là
sont sans électricité certains
attendront près de deux semaines avant
d'être rebranché
les Forces armées canadiennes
interviennent là aussi la crise coûte la
vie à deux personnes
puis en 2019 dans les régions de
l'outaway et de celle du nord de
Montréal on reçoit 20 mm de pluie
verglaçante le lendemain une épaisse
couche de neige vient complexifier le
travail des autorités alors que 316 000
clients ou plus fort de la panne sont
privés courants autant d'événements
étanches qui chaque fois coûte des
sommes faramineuses ici Elisa serre a
donc au Canada Montréal